[Music]  now the work that I'm most proud of is a  result of a 10-year long collaboration  with a scientist who studies  hummingbirds this is a story on what we  have learned about hummingbirds thanks  to modern science  the most fun I had working on this  project was getting to point the  high-speed camera at hummingbirds to  show these discoveries in a new way  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  we are in the lab of Chris Clark at UC  Riverside and what we've got here is a  cage that's recreating an experiment and  it's trying to look at how hummingbirds  deal with rain that we're using this  fancy top-of-the-line  complex 4k high-speed camera try to film  this hummingbird at 1,000 frames a  second to see how it's going to deal  with this  all these rain droplets and what its  gonna do the Friday zone and it is that  sense of wonder and that joy of  discovery that drew me to photography  and it is those feelings I hope to spark  another  [Music]